so this is a massive
massive win for the people i guess who
were censored and first among them is
miranda divine who was censored when she
tried to tell the truth before the
election she's the author of the laptop
from hell columnist the new york post
were happy to ever join us tonight
miranda
i mean how does this feel to have the
new york times
um admit that you were right all along
well it's kind of delicious to see them
sort of squirming around trying to admit
the obvious but you know if you're a
reader of the new york post or a viewer
of fox news you knew this 16 months ago
you didn't need the great new york times
to tell you that it was true and that
they'd authenticated the emails we
already did that and uh we published uh
truth the stories that were real and
have continued to do so without fear or
favor but unfortunately the new york
times readers have been kept in the dark
by their their newspaper their organ of
choice and that was for deliberate
reasons it was because they wanted
donald trump to lose the 2020 election
so all journalistic ethics and standards
went out the window and it doesn't
matter how you try and dress it up now
and pretend that you just found out even
if you didn't have the laptop as you
know because you interviewed tony
bobolinsky at the time he was a patriot
a hero who stood up against his own
interests to tell the world the truth
about joe biden and about his influence
peddling the way he abused his power to
make money from foreign countries uh
at the expense of america's national
interest and we're now reaping the uh
the spoils of that and i think you know
ultimately what we need to know now that
we're all on the same page now that we
agree that reality is reality what do we
do next and i think the next step is to
actually look at the evidence of
wrongdoing by the president uh and his
family obviously but he's the important
one
that's contained in the laptop and do
something about it
and throw off the censorship regime that
began that day when they censored you
they knocked parlor off the internet
we've never really recovered from that i
mean everything we say is now censored
and no one says anything about it
yes and also the 50 uh former
intelligence people i mean that was john
brennan a former recent head of the cia
that was leon panetta that was james
clapper and michael hayden these people
who now are to this day appearing on cnn
and msnbc as esteemed experts on russia
and ukraine and uh those people should
never hold their heads up in public
again they have been com their
reputations are destroyed by the fact
they signed that letter and lied about
the laptop and said without looking at
it that it was russian disinformation
and they got joe biden off the hook
you think of all the people have been
destroyed for nothing some stupid
comment you know and then the criminals
walk free a lot of them miranda devine
thank you
thanks so much tucker hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else